we often hear that exercise can help
with weight loss by speeding up or
boosting our metabolism so is it true
can we use exercise to control our
metabolism
[Music]
to answer that question we have to first
dig deeper into what metabolism is no
surprise metabolism is really complex
and scientists and researchers are still
discovering many new things about it
very simply metabolism is the set of
chemical reactions in every cell of our
body that harnesses energy to Keep Us
Alive so much of what happens in our
bodies is metabolism making new cells as
metabolism growing hair is metabolism
and converting food into energy is
metabolism the sum total energy of all
the metabolic processes that occur
throughout our body is measured in
calories and surprisingly exercise is
usually a small percentage of our daily
calorie burn unless you're a
professional athlete most of our calorie
expenditure is accounted for by our
basal metabolic rate all the vital stuff
we need to function like having a
heartbeat growing hair do building cells
and even blinking that stuff takes up a
big chunk of our energy so can we hack
this equation in some way can we use
exercise to speed up our metabolism so
we burn more energy and we burn even
more calories not just doing burpees but
while we're growing an eyelash than
before the answer is no first of all
this is the misunderstanding of what
fast versus slow metabolism really
indicates there's no clear link between
thinner people and vast metabolism and
the same goes for larger people and slow
metabolism in fact if you look at the
absolute numbers people with larger
bodies have faster metabolisms meaning
they burn more calories because larger
bodies have more cells which in turn are
doing more to sustain the body now
differences in metabolism between people
with similar body sizes do exist but the
difference between fast math metabolism
and slow metabolism can be about 300
calories that's like two apples and a
banana how fast our metabolism works is
mostly genetic and related to body size
but there's also age our metabolic rate
changes a few times over our lifespan we
start with the metabolic rate of an
infant then there is a switch when we
are toddlers and then it's pretty stable
during adulthood to age 60 when it
changes again researchers evaluated the
hadza a group of people in Tanzania who
live a traditional hunter-gatherer
lifestyle and yet when you control for
body size and age they burn a similar
amount of calories a day as an average
American adult it seems that calories
out is a pretty fixed number and it
appears that our bodies have limits if
we exercise harder at first we may
expend more energy but over time our
metabolism will find ways to conserve
here's what I'm getting at the point of
our metabolic system is to manage energy
not to manage weight so if you read an
article or hear a so-called expert
inviting you to boost your metabolism
remember that's just marketing speak
rooted in weight loss culture and just
isn't true